the biggest upside surprises are going
to come from the genomic space
we are in a world where
uh the dollar just fundamentally debases
naturally as you print more money
our strategy is to buy super high
quality dominant
companies that can withstand a pandemic
want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn where you
should be investing your money enjoy
okay let's kick it off with investment
number one invest in innovation with
kathy wood
what we think is not well understood is
exponential growth
i think if we uh step back and look at
amazon in the early 2000s
i remember buying that stock and uh many
people
derided that decision because uh the
thought process back then
is in the tech and telecom bust which is
you know the internet is a figment of
wall street's imagination what makes you
think amazon's
ever going to make any money and if
if if you did at that time
assume that amazon's revenue growth
would
compound at a 20 to 30 percent rate for
the next 20 years
you would have you would have bought
that stock all day long even if you were
using a dividend discount model
right i feel like our portfolios are
filled with
uh amazons uh because the seeds for what
we were doing
what we are doing now they were planted
in the tech and telecom bubble
and they have been gestating all this
time and now they're breaking out to
those growth trends
just like amazon did so the portfolio
may not be able to replicate
the 500 plus percent gain it's had in
the past five years
but it should be based on what you just
told me well over 100
percent it should double plus in this in
the next five years
yes we we expect more than a doubling
in our portfolios over the next five
years
if i look backward as you well know
tesla accounts for almost a fifth of the
return that you have generated in that
five-year time span
which of your current holdings kathy do
you think
will supply the biggest lift in the next
five years
tesla's still in the running but i would
have to say
the biggest upside surprises are going
to come from the genomic space
and that's because the convergence of
dna sequencing
uh artificial intelligence and gene
therapies
importantly crispr gene editing are
going to
cure disease that convergence is going
to cure disease
now we have real science and technology
surfacing the mutations in our genomic
profile
and um and as they surface those
mutations
what do we see we see the earliest
manifestations of disease
and now with the combination of
artificial intelligence and gene editing
we're able to both anticipate diseases
and cure them potentially beta
thalassemia we're seeing it sickle cell
disease
we even think it will work in uh
diabetes which is where
most the the if you look at the largest
category of spending
uh year-to-year in health care it's
diabetes kathy
another surprise for me in your
portfolio attribution
is that almost none of your performance
just 20 points out of 600 points
is from apple microsoft amazon and
facebook the four biggest contributors
to the s p
500 over the same period what about them
does it make the grade
for kathy wood and for arc well we're
not saying they'll be bad stocks at all
in fact they've been very good stocks
and they were a part of our portfolios
in the early days
uh but as they were scaling into the
trillion dollar category
uh we believed that our uh
that that our research would be focused
better on the next set of fangs
and i don't mean fangs meaning in the
internet age we actually think the next
fangs are in the genomic age
and if you'll notice our flagship
portfolio the largest exposure is
healthcare
for that reason investment number two
get real estate with cash flow
with grant cardone so i started studying
because i love real estate i'm like i
need to buy
real estate the cash flows not real
estate
what real estate is going to cash flow
today next month
next year and 10 years from now
apartments
what do you think since 1945
the rents in america have gone up since
world war ii
look at how many recessions we've had
between 1945 and 2017
at 70 years and rinse did this the whole
time
that's a graph ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding you don't stop
you don't stop 50 you're trends you
don't stop 50-year trends
okay so it leads me down to what
apartments right
it gives me apartments and it leads me
at mobile homes leaves me in storage i
need to focus on one of these because
i'm a focused person i'm not going to
try to do everything
so i started looking at apartments can i
understand apartments first thing i ever
bought was a single family home i put a
renter in it if you know my story i put
a runner in it renter moved out
i was like oh that doesn't work sold it
got rid of it i said i'll never do that
again what did i do wrong
one door one door okay if you're taking
notes and you want to go do this
yourself i'll help you do it yourself by
the way you don't have to invest with me
okay never buy one door ever
you want to buy lots of doors the more
doors the better
the more the number of units the most
important number in real estate
the single most important number and
brandon will talk to you about this
tomorrow
in any business the most important
number
is the number of in this case units
in a business it would be volume it
would be it would be it could be square
footage it's going to be
huh it would be how many times can you
multiply
that unit times and the bigger you can
get that number that's why netflix works
facebook works
amazon works because these people are
trying to scale that number of units
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here
investment number three get into crypto
why are you excited about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies
well i i i mean i think look if you go
back to
18 whatever um
you know we are in a world where
the dollar just fundamentally debases
naturally as you print more money
like literally by printing more
we actually make every single existing
one worth slightly less
so you eventually in a digital economy
will have to come and reckon with that
um
at the same time the way that people
deal with the financialization of all of
the things that have happened in the
economy
is that they try to hedge and the
problem with all of that is that it
actually creates very interlinked
dependencies
so it's a setup where on the one hand
the core underlying asset that people
use to price risk
is you know uh it degrades in value by
you know four five six percent in a good
year and in the year like last year
fifteen twenty percent because we
printed literally so much money
on the one hand and on the other hand
you have fundamental correlated risk
with everything
so if you want some instrument of value
to underpin a digital economy it will
have to be a cryptocurrency
and the more distributed it is uh the
less manipulated it can be
um and so that's why crypto and and
frankly it's why it's why um it's why
bitcoin
um and then you know if you then move
past that and say okay how can we do
functional things
with all of that then you're probably in
a world of uh d5 and ethereum and you
know
stuff investment number four invest in
super dominant companies with bill
ackman
our strategy is to buy super high
quality dominant
uh companies that can withstand a
pandemic or
a dramatic movement in interest rates
that are not particularly exposed to the
economy
uh so you know who the president is it's
not something that we would make a bet
one way or another on the portfolio our
principles are basically one invest in
simple predictable free cash
regenerative
dominant companies with large barriers
to entry that are in high returns on
capital
that have limited exposure to extrinsic
risk we can't control
strong balance sheets don't need access
to capital to survive have excellent
management good governance
sounds logical um but you know
occasionally
we've diverged and there's uh those
times you know
there's a certain discipline that comes
with investments and there always seems
to be a
countervailing quality that caused us to
diverge
but in really each case we've
compromised on business quality or
complexity
we've been harmed from an investment
standpoint if you're passive you can
feel like the market's patsy and if
you're active
you can actually create some value and i
think it's a lot more interesting
than just picking securities you know we
bought a stake in chipotle at a time
where the company was struggling a few
years ago
we put a few directors on the board we
recruited a new ceo named brian nichol
it's completely turned around the
company the stock is you know almost
tripled
in in the midst of a crisis uh and it
just tells you that you know
that's a lot more fun and it's a lot
more profitable and i would say bet
good for a lot more good for america
than just simply being a passive stock
picker
and investment number five the last one
before very special bonus clip
is diversify with ray dalio is that you
as well because you're
more diversified when i look at the way
you set up your portfolio it's not as
niche as that uh
i'm big on diversity you're very big on
diversification knowing how
knowing how to adversify well is more
important than almost anything people
don't understand
this is that an evergreen principle yes
that's an evergreen principle
interesting
and the reason i'm saying that the way
it is it's almost like a casino making
its
money okay okay the way that you do it
is you get an
edge so now when you have to make a bet
i've got a bet against the whole world
the world has
view on something is reflected in the
price so
when i think something is attractive or
unattractive
that means i have to bet against the
whole world and whether that's right or
not
that's difficult i get it right you know
more often than i get it wrong
but i'm going to get it wrong sometimes
and so
when you can take a lot of different
bets
what you can do is like the casino
you'll get your average that your bet
would be but you'll reduce your risk
of one of those tables not being the
table that's paying off
and so that margin then so i can reduce
my risk
without reducing my return by knowing
how to diversify
and i'd say that's particularly true
important for for the people who are
listening you're investors
because what they've got to reduce risk
without reducing return
that's right that's the specialty that's
right elaborate a little bit more if you
don't mind on that so reducing risk
without
reducing the uh return because a lot of
times if i'm
reducing the risk it means my return is
also going lower but you're saying no
we're reducing it without even reducing
the return right
i mean that's a high paying skill set to
have
it's the most important thing that you
could start off doing
if you have a number of equally good
likely bets but they're uncorrelated
like the casino you know one table
is going to gank me a margin like this
but
take another table and it makes me a
margin like this
but i might have volatility about those
let me take all those investments that i
think will make 10
so that's my return but they're
uncorrelated with each other
that means i'll still get the 10 i don't
lower my 10
but my diversification means i lower my
risk
so i improve my return to risk ratio
ah is that an art that you can teach oh
yeah
yeah i wrote about it in there's a what
i call a section in this book
the holy grail of investing it's a
three pages long and it explains
basically
this important thing because when that
epiphany happened to me
and how i would do it it changed
everything by
being able to do that because how old
were you when you can improve through
diversification
i could improve my return to risk ratio
by a factor of five so
by diversifying okay
the return relative to the risk i can
keep my returns the same
and reduce my risk to one-fifth
if i know how to diversify well and
that's why i'm explaining it's not all
that
complicated it's simply explained in the
book but in any case
that is the holy grail of investing
okay that's a big thing if you start to
know that that's what you're going for
it changes everything the real question
for me was what were the marginal
benefits of diversification like
how it you know what is that going to
look like okay
and what i then decided to do
was to think about risk
and the number of sample size
and the correlation of the bets broke it
down to
each of its components right so
to use an example let's assume you have
to make it simple a return something
that has a 10
risk we'll call risk standard deviation
and let's make it simple and let's say
it had a 10 return
and let's say i add in another asset
another return asset return stream
i add in a second a third a fourth a
fifth
up to whatever number how would that
reduce my risk if it on average has a 60
correlation or if it has an average has
a 40
correlation or a zero percent
correlation
how would that change wanted to know
that right
so that's what this chart shows right
and so so imagine you have a 10
average return you don't know which bet
is going to be better has a 10
average return and a 10 risk
and you add in a second and a third and
so on
you're not going to lose the 10 because
you're still going to have that 10
percent return
but you're going to then have a
reduction and that's the reduction in
risk
and if it has a 60 correlation and you
have
three or four you will get a reduction
that
maybe is about 15 and you could add in a
thousand
if they're 60 correlated and you're not
going to reduce your risk much
okay that's important now if i look at
that how that changes
according to the levels of the
correlation i start to think well
what would happen if i added in
something that had a 10
correlation by way of example okay
now that's what that line shows okay and
it shows how much
okay at about seven or eight
or so i cut my risk in half that means
i've doubled my return
relative to my risk right oh that's good
so as i go down this i then start to
understand what the power of
diversification is
in terms of the things that i'm going to
look for so
what that taught me is
the magic is an only
you only need to do this simple thing
the simple thing is to find
15 or 20 good
uncorrelated return streams things that
are probably going to make money but you
don't know but they have a good
probability of making money
and that but you have that are
uncorrelated
that have low correlation that told me
that's what i have to go after
right that's the key
a lot of people think that the most
important thing you could do is find the
best investments okay that's important
okay but there is no great one best
investment
that can compete with something like
this so look at this line
when this comes down you can improve
your
return to risk ratio by a factor of five
right five times the expected return for
that unit
of risk you can't pick any investments
that are probably
numbers humanly capable in an efficient
market probably
to pick investments that are five times
as good individually but
so that path so it tells me about the
power
of diversification and balancing risk so
this is the return to risk ratio that
happens for
each one of those you know like if i can
get zero correlation
and i have 15 to 20 i'll have an
information ratio
a return to risk ratio of 1.25 that
means my probability
of losing money in a year is only 11
okay as this thing from 40 percent with
any one of us
so that's the power of portfolio
construction and the power of
diversification
okay so it tells me what i have to go
after
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated inspired
you have a 35 chance of following
through but when you get motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you when you
sold
micro solutions for a couple million
dollars um i read that six million don't
push it down
i got a couple million but that's that's
nothing right compared to now
it's a lot trust me but you took that
money and then you invested it
into other technology stocks that you
knew
and then you took that and then went
from broadcast.com and then
boom you know right everything what were
those stocks that you invested in so we
teach our kids
um kind of the peter lynch adage invest
in what you know
yeah and i think you took and that's
exactly what i did i mean look i spent
seven years um installing local area
networks writing software
um doing wide area networks and so
i knew what a router you know which
companies routers worked and didn't work
which which companies bridges and
software worked and didn't work
um which products were selling um which
products weren't
and so i i use that to my advantage
because back
back then it was a little bit easier
because there weren't as many people
there weren't as many analysts
covering everything yeah right and so
i was all these huge head fun hedge
funds once they saw that i was killing
it they were like okay we're going to
talk to this guy
and literally took my trading experience
i was making 8 500
a year and created a hedge fund out of
it
and oh yeah and then we just immediately
sold it so it turned out really well
um but i did that now and i'm telling
you
the peter lynch experience is going to
be interesting in terms of okay where do
you shop what do you do
what websites you go to but if you
take the time to learn computer vision
neural networks and everything
that's what that's how all the decisions
are go a lot of decisions are going to
be made but all decisions are going to
be influenced
and so if you really want to get to that
point you know if you look at some of
the hottest stocks right now
nvidia amd they're just
they're blowing up because of their
ability to create processors
that are geared towards um towards
artificial intelligence and and
supporting the data centers
if you look at what's happening with
amazon you know
i own a lot of amazon stock um because
they are the most advanced in using all
these things i've been talking about
you know netflix you know they started
10 years ago
by using um their you know
their versions of artificial
intelligence back then to try to
determine what's the best way to help
guide people to through choosing content
yeah through the whole discovery they
had a million dollar contest
and so you know artificial intelligence
is going to eat the world
and so the peter lynch approach is great
but you have to
um you have to be where the decision
yeah you have to understand that right
it's just it's which is not an easy
no and plus the other problem is there's
a lot fewer companies
going public these days right back when
we went public 20 years ago there were 9
000
um companies that were public now
there's under 4
000 and so there's more money chasing
fewer choices
which is good on in some respects but
you know it's and it's good because all
that money helped push helps push the
indexes up
right lots of money fewer stocks you
know so you don't have as many
choices um but it's bad in that
there aren't as many new companies
coming out where you can say okay
you know so and so is going public i
know that company most other people
don't
and that might give me an edge in my
investing right your ubers and your
airbnb yeah
yeah and snapchat right snapchat's
supposed to go public airbnb and uber
and let me okay so let's talk about
big-time screw-ups in investing yeah
yeah
so there's a guy named travis clonic
right and he had a company
called red swoosh yeah and i invested in
it and we sold it and we made a little
bit of money his next company he emails
me
he's got this thing called uber cab and
he's like you should invest in this mark
i'm like i like it it's a great idea
you're gonna run into some resistance
from all the
the taxi cab companies and all the
transportation folks in
in different cities that are gonna hate
you so you know i like the idea
but i don't like the way you're pricing
it never heard back from them again
now that's my problem with travis
personally but
obviously it turned into uber and so
sometimes you make it and sometimes you
miss them
[Music]
if you want to know ray dalio's best
investment advice check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there when i was 12
i hated school but i fell in love with
trading the markets
i caddied at the time earned about five
dollars a bag and i took my cutting
money
and i put it in the stock market